[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new iron man video
marvel phase 4 the avengers what if
trailer so we'll break it down they're a
bunch of easter eggs and i'll talk about
what's going on with iron man coming
back
in the mcu in the twisty ways that
they're using to accomplish that
comic con is also happening next week
i'll be doing videos for that so be sure
to subscribe to get all those videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know how you want them to
bring iron man back in marvel phase 4
without having to bring him back to life
so start at the beginning number five
everyone wants to know when iron man is
gonna show up in the mcu again and how
he'll show up because kevin feige the
russos the writers of avengers endgame
have all been pretty clear on the same
story point iron man died during
avengers end game
they're not going to undo that sacrifice
by just bringing him right back to life
like they're not going to use an
infinity gauntlet to snap him back to
life
so their options for iron man appearing
in new marvel movies in the disney plus
series gets a little sci-fi a little
weird
a while ago jeff goldblum let slip that
iron man was featured
during the marvel what if series this is
the clip of him talking about that
um hey we're we're talking about it in
fact you know i
i hope so i love taika ytt he's a great
director and a friend of mine so i hope
so but i played the part
again a couple of days ago i went to the
disney studios
uh and i recorded the grand master's
voice
for an episode of a show that's going to
be on disney plus called what if
where it's an animated version of all
the characters we know and love from
marvel and this episode included the
grand master and iron man so robert
downey
will do a voice in that and korg taika
ytt will do
had already recorded his voice for that
so yeah i enjoyed for a couple hours i
enjoyed
doing that again so uh the grand master
is uh
as well based on what marvel is doing
with the what if series on disney plus
it sounds like they're starting with a
multiverse
alternate reality explainer as a way to
get characters back
that's not the only way they bring
robert downey jr back but according to
jeff goldblum it just seems like it's
one of the ways that they're trying to
bring him back
marvel's been pretty open about how the
multiverse is so critical to their
marvel phase 4
stories like doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness it's literally in the title
of that movie
what if was originally just a comic book
narrated by the watcher having fun with
the concept what if
major comic book battle happened in a
different way usually it's just one key
difference
but that leads to a vastly different
outcome sometimes it was a monkey's paw
situation and things go
terribly for whoever the protagonist is
and sometimes it just gets super cool
and super weird
the mcu marvel what if episodes so far
just based on the trailer footage in the
episodes they've told us about are a
little more straightforward at least
during season one
so number four this is what robert
downey jr had to say
so far about coming back as iron man and
this is him talking about coming back
fully in live-action mcu movies like
coming back in a big avengers movie
if you don't remember this is him
talking about this on joe rogan with joe
rogan trying to get him to come back
is the door to iron man totally closed
because i don't believe it is oh
you guys can go through time now you can
go there's there was
you know you already opened up that door
let me ask you the question
if i picked the jersey back up and put
it on wouldn't you feel a little bit
like uh
crap no oh here's here's what i think
they go through a few
semi lackluster avengers movies without
you
you ready for this i'm ready here's the
scene there's a moment
where the world's fate is at stake and
they've realized they need a super
genius
and then they figure out how to restart
that time machine come on man
is that you the audience sees you when
you when you step out of that thing
is this your and can we you want a
little arc on it too because if this is
your idea then you've got to show up for
it too
i'll do it i'll show up what i have to
do i don't know i'll do whatever i have
to do
we all have to do whatever kevin
feinstein holds the thing
do they still have that they do they do
it's digital
i hold that digital thing i'll do it but
the the way people would freak out if
you came back
so the way robert downey jr makes it
sound he's taking an indefinite hiatus
from the big marvel movies just in
general right now like joe rogan's
trying to get him to say yes to coming
back because how cool would that be
and robert danny jr agrees with him like
okay sure it would be kind of cool
but in reality his tone implies it's
probably going to be a long time before
that happens
but what he's talking about during that
conversation is coming back as the main
character
in a big avengers level movie like the
whole plot of the movie would revolve
around him
there's a big difference between that
and then bringing iron man as a
character back in a smaller role
in other projects because the very first
place we're reportedly going to see iron
man come back
in a marvel movie is actually if you can
believe it in the black widow movie
reportedly the way they were bringing
him back in the black widow movies
because that movie is said in the past
right after captain america civil war
they were supposed to use some deleted
scenes from civil war that they filmed
with robert downey jr
in new context with the black widow
character so it would have felt like
brand new scenes but in reality it's
really just footage that robert downey
jr
shot a long time ago number three the
marvel what if episode that jeff
goldblum is talking about
when he's referencing iron man was the
thor ragnarok episode earlier this year
after jeff goldblum did this interview
there was a report that came out
claiming that he had been mistaken when
he was talking about iron man being in
that thor ragnarok episode
but kevin feige said that they were
doing one what if episode for every
single mcu movie
and there are only 10 episodes in season
1 of the what if series
that's gonna start next summer too for
those of you wondering when the episodes
are actually coming
so all the marvel movies so far won't
even be covered till at least season 2
or season 3 potentially
so we're talking about iron man mcu what
if episodes for the three different iron
man movies not counting any of the
avengers
what-if episodes that they'll do for
those movies they just didn't have
robert downey jr under a new contract
to come back for the episodes when it
was time to announce the series
so it just means that it'll probably be
a while before we see the iron man
marvel what-if episodes and they're just
going to hold out to try and get robert
downey jr to come back
number two there are a couple major iron
man what-if moments from the movies in
the comics that they've teased before
and are perfect
what if stories the biggest one being
the avengers infinity war deleted scene
of the iron mage
in dr stark sorcerer supreme no joke
they actually filmed this scene but it
wound up hitting the cutting room floor
during the edit but during avengers
infinity war
when iron man and spider-man go on board
ebony maw's q-ship
to save doctor strange in the time stone
what was supposed to happen was iron man
uses his nano armor to cover doctor
strange protecting him from ebony moss
needles
and the armor looks like this on him
notice that instead of the arc reactor
in the middle the armor forms around the
eye of agamotto in the time stone
and when he was like that they called
him the iron mage
and after this happened because iron man
is defenseless and he was saving doctor
strange the cloak of levitation which is
sentient
does him a solid forms around him and
levitates iron man down to the floor
as they both fight off ebony maw wearing
each other's armor
there was also some footage of this
during the trailers that marvel released
before avengers
infinity war came out when something
cool like that happens and it winds up
being a deleted scene
sometimes marvel will try to use that
idea in a new movie and they don't want
to spoil that
like we have doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness coming up kevin feige
revealed that we'd see alternate
versions of main
mcu heroes it would be really cool if
they tried to include that
iron mage twist during doctor strange 2.
there's even a whole marvel what-if
comic book based on that concept what if
iron man became sorcerer's supreme
it doesn't end well for him in that
story but he winds up weaving together a
lot of tech and magic to create this
cool magical armor with a lot of spells
auto programmed into it to go fight big
demons
if you're not a big comic book reader
that is exactly what dr doom does he's a
man of science just like iron man but
also a man of
magic just like doctor strange he's like
an evil version of iron man who's also a
really powerful magic user so that is
why i'm really excited for mcu doctor
doom
but number one all the big comic con in
marvel phase four schedule changes that
they just announced
so next week is comic con but marvel
studios is supposedly skipping it and
they're gonna do their own thing later
this year
it's not that big of a deal though
they'll start releasing trailers and
everything later this summer in the fall
the next big schedule change though is
for falcon and winter soldier marvel
just confirmed that it's been delayed a
little while
now it's coming out sometime in the fall
the fall season starts in september so
that means that's the earliest that
falcon and winter soldier could
start reportedly marvel is going to
confirm all that schedule stuff pretty
soon so don't worry too much about that
black widow has not changed yet though
it's still supposed to come out in
november
but new mutants is actually supposed to
come out in august
they might change that to a video on
demand release they're doing a comic-con
panel next week for that movie so if
they announce anything of course i'll do
a video for it
but everyone let me know in the comments
how do you want them to bring iron man
back in marvel phase 4 without having to
bring him back to life
congratulations matthew smith you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for that really cool
video of superman henry cavill building
himself a superhero gaming pc for the
first time
and click here to learn how marvel is
supposedly bringing thanos back
in future marvel movies thank you so
much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
you